hey there you go sit down man clear the
seat out yo some joke yeah you do look
like I'm talking to to mere man aina huh
that's watch yourselves anybody cut
hey ray alright okay let me clean that
up
watch your leg Joey that glass can get
into your skin you can't get it out
brother I got a new hobby red happy yes
mixology man it's my new thing
okay you know you got to go to school
for bartending you know I don't have to
go to school for nothing okay I took a
nap man
yes download app on my phone mix algae
at reddit two minutes I got it all in my
head right yeah people study for years
to become good bartenders you gonna
learn from my ass saying people study
for years are the same people that
created the app so I don't have to study
theater
give me let me drive I don't that's not
it man
I don't know what I will not to do all
right let me let me make it simple give
me a gin and juice that's easy that's we
talk about drinks from the states are
you guys in Japan where yeah let's let's
talk about the ingredients are in the
name kids brother if I'm a mixologist
let me mix okay let me let me bring to
you what I do best
come here huh go boy huh is it a
basketball is in the bottle yeah man huh
just just your lawn poor short poor I
just wanna give it all Oh still in a
glass yes still in a glass who like dark
I can't see nothing cuz I like dark boy
watch this mm hit him with it splash
that on right you think brother
y'all like al-azhar no Rand
everything oh Mack - Mack I'm not gonna
start it's just I'm not a joke come here
Joey Mauro Joey brother let me show you
something I'm done
this didn't taste what I got Harry Harry
Joe rake huh it's called a doohickey
dirt right hey disgusting
you
[Music]